even just a few months ago this site
would have seemed extraordinary
a masked prime minister arriving at
westminster abbey to be welcomed by
masked military
a masked clergy but as the trappings of
the pandemic become ever more familiar
the government is concerned compliance
with restrictions is diminishing
and new national measures may be needed
the nation faces a
tipping point and we have a choice
and the choice is either that everybody
follows the rules
the rule of six and the need to
self-isolate if you have a positive test
or if you're contacted by
nhs test and trace or
we will have to take more measures
but the labour leader says the
government should be admitting that its
own failings have contributed to the
current situation
rather than blaming the public because
the government's now
effectively lost control of testing it
doesn't necessarily know where the virus
is so you know if i was the prime
minister i would
apologize for the fact that testing is
all over the place and instead of using
the summer to
prepare for the autumn which is what we
said should happen uh we're in this
position just when we need testing to be
at its very best ministers have spent
the weekend examining the options
available for new measures
including what's been described as a
two-week circuit breaker lockdown
which could see pubs restaurants and
leisure activities closed for a
fortnight
to curb the spike in infections but one
leading scientist told sky news such
action could be jumping the gun
and should instead be used at a point
when the seasonal prevalence of the
virus is likely to be more dangerous
often when we come back in january
there's a significant rise in deaths in
the month of january
about 5000 per week more than what we
see
right now and that's due to the seasonal
effects
therefore if you're looking at a break
and when we need it we need it in the
mid-winter
when we might run into problems but
actually it would be more explainable to
people why we're doing it then
than now there's no evidence right now
of what's called a second wave
these are high pressure decisions for
the prime minister what he does this
week could define his political future
boris johnson has set his stall on
preventing another full
national lockdown and so to avoid
failure by his own metrics
he needs any new measures that are
introduced by the government to be
effective and to bring case rates down
but that could all be hampered
by his own back benches some of whom
feel that the existing regulations go
too far
and they may yet mount a rebellion in
parliament
the task for the government is to stem
the rise of infections
while keeping the public and the
conservative party on board
missteps or indecision this week could
result
in the opposite tom rayner sky news
westminster